[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[ __ ] this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the tony
michaels podcast and this is tony
michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
well happy thursday afternoon
or morning wherever you are in the
country
it's noon
and you know what time that is it's time
for let's talk to tony michael's podcast
we are gonna go through the [ __ ] list
roundup today
a lot of stuff to get to
i think there's some stuff we even
missed yesterday on the [ __ ] list
roundup
see i'm still getting used to this see
this see this i'm still getting used to
this
we'll get it we'll look at it eventually
we'll get it eventually we'll work out
all the kinks speaking of kinks
speaking of kinks um apparently
fox news you know they had their little
way with the the the m m's the other day
you know how sexy are non-sexy the m and
m ms are uh today they're on disney they
just can't help but uh have kinks over
cartoons so we're probably
oh they're worried about minnie mouse
wearing pant suits
this is [ __ ] dumb these are the
culture wars they want to have folks
this is it this is the culture wars they
want to have this is how [ __ ]
ridiculous we get we gotta lead a lot of
people in here midas lisa uh leah says
hi all
uh minus lisa you're walking your dogs
for this episode fantastic maybe the
dogs can
can get fired up too
um yeah someone said stephanie rule is
taking over the 11th hour and we might
get we might get to the msnbc stuff
uh yoder says good morning [ __ ] and
fuckets and tony hello yoda good morning
to you
thanks for joining us here on
let's talk the tony michaels podcast
we're going to get to the [ __ ] list
roundup but before we do i want to make
some announcements
i want to make some announcements
we weren't able to get the interview
ready for today and tomorrow we're doing
bonehead so it looks like that interview
is going to be on monday i will tell you
who it is though uh it's missy modell
uh she does a lot of parody songs on
tiktok and instagram oh chris in hey
chris one of our hate watchers uh
caitlyn's here says hey [ __ ] army hey
kaylan how are you good morning good
morning all
but anyways the the the interview missy
modell she does uh song parodies and
satire which is difficult in this day
and age because these [ __ ] idiots are
parody of themselves i mean literally
candace owens
talking about how [ __ ] minnie mouse
is wearing a goddamn pantsuit and it's
offensive or some [ __ ] i don't know what
the [ __ ] she's talking about that's a
saturday night live skit they can't even
write that [ __ ]
that's that [ __ ] funny that you laugh
and clown these [ __ ]
we're in a situation where you can't
parody but missy does a wonderful job
with her music at parroting these
[ __ ] idiots
so go over and check out missy modell
she's on twitter
uh follow her there because she's not on
twitter much we're trying to pull her
over to twitter get her on twitter but
she's on tick tock she's on the
instagrammies so go go go the grammy
grams whatever it is over there on
instagram follow her there and follow
her on tic tac if you're on tick tock
and uh that that'll be on monday it
looks like the missy modell interview
it's really fun now we talk a lot about
trolls
um you know trolls for content creators
how trolls just don't like they just
don't get it
and also we we play trivia a real fun
trivia game so
don't don't make sure not to miss that
on monday tomorrow though tomorrow noon
eastern 11th century you know we're here
every single week day two hours every
single weekday tomorrow the second hour
we'll have bonehead of the week if you
guys haven't went over to
uh the twitter page and voted uh here's
your chance now at tony michael's pod go
over there
the the poll is over there for bone hint
of the week
um it looks like matt gatz is going to
get the dishonorable mention
for some of the crazy stuff that's
happening in the joel greenberg case i
don't know if you guys have seen some of
the stuff going on
but uh there was another uh plea deal in
the joel greenberg matt gatt sex
trafficking case
it looks like that's gonna heat up soon
so
you know
i guess i guess we are not able
we're in a world where we can't jerk off
to eminem's
and minnie mouse anymore get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] let's start
the countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast for the [ __ ] list
roundup where we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends of the day
there's there's a few of them today and
some of them are just absolutely [ __ ]
ridiculous i can't even believe like the
other day i did 20 minutes 20 [ __ ] 25
minutes
on clowning these [ __ ] about m
m's and how sexy they are they aren't
and how they're you know i know i don't
know they're having sex with them i
don't know what the hell they're doing
with the m m's now it's minnie mouse
candace owens is completely offended
that minnie mouse wears pantsuits and
the pantsuits look better on minnie
mouse than they do on her
anytime you see a picture of [ __ ]
candace owen that that [ __ ] is wearing a
goddamn pant suit why the [ __ ] does she
give a [ __ ] what they draw minnie mouse
in
why who gives a [ __ ]
she's in a dress i've seen her in like
like overalls gardening
she's been in an astronaut suit all
kinds of [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] cartoon
dummy what the [ __ ] do you care so we're
gonna go through that uh some other
things some other topics that we got we
got the biden boom going on
obviously the economy is growing
more and more people are spending money
because there's high demand out there
which is a good thing
like all these things are good things
people wanting to spend money that's a
good thing people spending money that's
a good thing for the economy when
there's high demand
that's a good sign
like that is the that's the the main
sign like if everyone stops buying [ __ ]
and there's no demand that's really
[ __ ] horrible
like that's when you got to start
worrying
all these people at the gas pump like oh
my gas is so hot cause of biden but i'm
gonna spend the 200 anyways because i
want to drive my big truck and and you
know make up for my little penis but i'm
gonna i'm gonna [ __ ] about it while i
buy the gas well the demand is up and
you're buying the gas
like that's the [ __ ] point
how don't you people see this now
inflation isn't is an issue for for
working class folks
but as far as the economy goes inflation
the as a whole inflation is not always
bad it's not and it's not bad for the
people who have the capital
why do you think inflation works
why do you think they want inflation
come on
just think about it for two seconds you
you people who have you [ __ ] gq peers
out there who claim to be free market
capitalists and know nothing not a god
damn thing
about capitalism let's see what else we
gonna listen to oh we have susan collins
on the list
uh spotify uh president pelosi
apparently uh nikki haley she wants uh
nancy pelosi to be the president um you
know i i mean i guess i guess that's
okay
i mean we didn't vote for her but if
that's what nikki haley wants by god
that's what nikki haley should get get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
geraldo's in the news i guess because of
the spotify thing of course tucker
carlson's in there too and clarence
thomas as well there's a lot of [ __ ] to
get to today
a lot of [ __ ]
on this list so let's uh let's go to the
timeline here let's make it bigger so
you guys can see
it
let's see um
yeah gay beers
mr potato heads name change a vaccinated
a big bird non-sexy m m's and now
pantsuits wearing minnie mouse
when will joe biden's end his reign of
terror
[Laughter]
oh my god
oh [ __ ] they really are stupid like gas
prices gas starts going down they're
like eminem's aren't sexy anymore like
what the [ __ ] are you people talking
about
and caitlin says good morning everyone
and a big [ __ ] you to susan collins yeah
we'll get to the big [ __ ] susan
collins
i miss the good old days when space
muppets could count on m m's and minnie
mouse as deposits in the spank bank too
all right thanks yoda for the comment
you know i'll pull them in if we got
them
now let's see what else we got here
uh
dude
oh that's that's that's that's in that
tweet okay let's go to this thread there
we go now we're in the right thread
uh mayo says betraying the american
people people is the job of tucker
carlson absolutely
uh let's see elgin oh this is this is
one of the best
if you want daily affirmations this is
who you go see you gotta go follow elgin
if you want daily affirmations
the today's was
in particularly
really really at my heart because it's
got the [ __ ] attitude right behind it
right
who cares if certain people don't like
you
they're probably struggling to like
themselves
perfect beautiful keep these up elgin i
love them i love them
keep up the daily affirmations that that
dude oh oh here here here's uh um if you
guys want to watch this i'm not going to
play it because of dmca you know they
had to ding me on [ __ ] youtube twitch
when they hear the sound right
but this is a great video from seinfeld
the scene where they have the 3d optical
illusions you guys remember these
[ __ ] paintings that you could buy
like in the 90s
and like you look at it for a while and
something would jump out of the [ __ ]
the painting and that's that's what this
is uh seinfeld was doing nfts on the
show before they were cool i guess i
guess there's something like um
uh
you can make your is it on twitter you
can make your [ __ ] av or whatever it
is an nft or some [ __ ] what is with this
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going on
what the hell is going on with this nft
crypto [ __ ]
i'm not on [ __ ] bored no
i haven't figured it out yet i guess
hell i don't know
maybe i will
maybe i won't let's see what else we got
oh this is a good one from paul
the right the right gets so triggered by
the mere mention of the word pantsuit
like they are man they are [ __ ]
triggered as [ __ ]
oh pant suit
email lady
benghazi like they go down this rabbit
hole
the minute the minute minnie mouse puts
on a pantsuit they lose their [ __ ]
minds i just can't help it um here's
here's what i said about susan collins
susan collins can take a [ __ ] hike
we stopped giving a [ __ ] about what she
thought ten oh they learned their
lessons ago the [ __ ] out of here with
this [ __ ] susan collins we're sick of
hearing your [ __ ] opinion why the
people
of maine put up with your [ __ ] i have no
idea of course now they got to put up
with your [ __ ] for a lot longer they had
the opportunity to get rid of you this
[ __ ]
here we are i also said what was the
world cup what is the world coming to
when you can't jerk off the m m's and
minnie mouse
right and it's a horrible world when you
get when you can't get off the candy oh
rachel rachel bitkoffer was on the show
yesterday
yes you guys did you guys watch the you
guys watch re-watch the rachel uh
conversation we had yesterday do you
like that you should go watch the uh i
posted it up on its own
on youtube so there's a clip over there
i think it's about 30 minutes or so that
we had a conversation so i posted the
the conversation that i had with uh the
political strategist rachel bitkoffer
from strike pack um yesterday she was on
the show a real good conversation a lot
of [ __ ] yous in there
if you like that kind of thing
uh it's over there on youtube so don't
don't forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel
um so that way you don't miss any of the
interviews that we post separately and
just hit the bell notification and hit
the like button and comment and like and
whatever the hell i'm supposed to say
you know i'm really good at the youtube
stuff so
i'm really good at the youtube stuff
telling you how to youtube
the tubes of you i don't know just do
whatever the hell makes it to wherever
you see the videos over there and you
get to watch them also i i would i would
go back and re-watch the the interview
we had with her a couple weeks ago um an
extended extended interview we we
actually played turvy and all that kind
of good stuff but she talks about
strategic outrage and that's what we
talked about yesterday with strategic
outrage
she says here this morning about the
biden boom
despite inheriting a pandemic left to to
fire out
of control flame out of control
price inflation from trump's tariff war
and a massive labor shortage from
trump's foolish immigration policies
dems brought us the best economic growth
5.7
americans seen since
1984 the biden
boom democrats deliver
that's what happens when that's what
happens when democrats are in charge of
governing they're in charge of
administrating their charge of
legislating
you have [ __ ] economic booms that's
what happens go back and look at the
[ __ ] books folks
go go see how republicans destroy the
economy every [ __ ] time no
matter what no matter what the case is
no matter if we have a pandemic no
matter if we have oh
the guy from texas wants to
cut taxes on the rich [ __ ] the middle
class
go go check it out go check out the
[ __ ] statistics on democrats
delivering for the economy
and you just see that democrats always
always govern and that's the difference
if if you would just [ __ ] govern and
do what's right for the
people and that's why that's why we have
to we have to push for pro-democracy
candidates
in this next midterm and the the problem
that we have in this country is there is
no bipartisanship anymore forget that
[ __ ] there is none
there is no bipartisanship you can't
work with people who want autocracy
in a democracy you cannot you can't do
it
why would you
if you want democracy why would you
compromise to autocracy why would you do
that
that's not democracy that's not how it
works that's not how we want it to work
compounding this messaging
thank you rachel for your insight into
how to frame this up
you guys need to go follow rachel by the
way
she's over there tweeting every day
teaching you how to frame up the
arguments
every single day teaching you how to do
it
but we have to have strategic outrage
it's not just about yelling and
screaming you know i say stay pissed go
[ __ ] vote so you have to stay pissed
like that's that's the part you got to
be pissed off about this stuff you got
to have that outrage but it's got to be
strategic so you got to go [ __ ] vote
and i don't just mean mark a ballot
you got to do the things
that are going to win us the election
and by us i mean pro-democracy
and again
fortunately or unfortunately in this
country the only goddamn party that's
interested in democracy right now
is the democrats that's it
republicans don't even want you to vote
not [ __ ] one of them not one of them
voted for the two voting rights act in
the house
not [ __ ] one republican not even the
ones that everyone thinks is on our side
that's gonna save us from trumpism liz
cheney and adam kinzinger they didn't
even vote for it
yep
you're wondering you're wondering you're
wondering who to vote for hmm
gabe here posted looks like matt gets
just became this week's dishonorable
mention make sure to vote in the
bonehead of the week here is the here is
the link
here it is
um give credit here
come on there we go i did it twice but
that's okay
i pushed the button twice
you guys heard the matt gets uh
you guys heard the matt gets news right
there's a new there's a new character
that has emerged
a talk radio show host i guess that was
uh friends with joel greenberg
and apparently this guy was dealing
adderall on venmo
um and somehow he's tied to matt gatz
and joel greenberg in this case i wonder
i wonder how many
how many pounds of adderall
matt gatt's vin mode
when you when you look at i guess
someone had a screenshot of this guy's
this ellicott or whatever this guy's
name is
he had a screenshot of his venmo and and
maddie maddie was on his was on his
friends list of people he pays hmm
wonder wonder what's going on there i
guess so
let's see uh let's let's this is uh
gabe's video of a matt gatz he did a
while back matt gatz is going to go
through some things
let's uh let's take a listen here looks
like looks like someone's gonna end up
in hell
you think so i mean you know mac hatch
is a good christian right
maybe you end up in hell let's see whoa
where am i the gates of hell like the
mad gates of hell hell no i shouldn't be
here i'm a good innocent christian
people don't beg trump for a blanket
pardon but sure let's go through the
list list in 2017 you were the only
congressman about no on the anti-human
trafficking bill well the thing about uh
in 2019 you tweeted that florida should
change his welcome signs to there is no
age that you can't be sexy recently you
made fake ideas with joel greenberg a
sex trafficker fake news there's video
evidence then you show nude photos of
women to other lawmakers on the house
floor there's a very good explanation
shut the hell up i'm not done yet
turns out you have some friends
with fellow florida lawmakers and you
also pay to have sex with minors even we
think that's gross mm-hmm
dumb do you have to be to pay for sex
with an app
right on schedule
little nausea will now be in charge of
your punishment
oh
who who else is in love with gabe's
videos i know you guys love gabe's
videos i know i know you i know you love
it
uh so uh speaking of matt gatz and and
some of the the list of [ __ ] that he's
done
uh cnbc did a uh american greed you guys
watch this show american greed i caught
i caught i finally caught it last night
because i don't have cable so i gotta
wait for like this [ __ ] to post up on
their website to where they're not you
know charging you for it and [ __ ] or
they'll let you watch it for free
so i had to wait for a while but the
joel greenberg um documentary or or or
the the
the the show american greed
was was posted on their website so i
went over watching on this joel
greenberg
and you can't even [ __ ] imagine like
you're like whoa i thought it was just
like
the skeezy ass sex trafficker no this
guy was [ __ ] taking coven money all
kinds of crazy ass [ __ ] and matt gatz
loves this guy like their best buddies
there's a voicemail out there somewhere
um that i've i've heard before and it
wasn't played on the show but you guys
should go watch the show um again i you
know i
you definitely should go i think you
just go to just just google american
greed
and uh it'll get you to the website and
and it's one of the i think it's like
the
the third episode or second episode from
the last one something like that but
it's the one on joel greenberg
and at the very end they they go through
some of the [ __ ] matt gatz has done um
you know in being investigated for
federal crimes of course we seen his
ex-girlfriend um seek immunity which
appears that she's gotten some sort of
immunity
but we also seen
um yesterday i believe or the day before
there was a guy named ellicott and we
talked about it here on um
the show
that he pled guilty and he was dealing
adderall like pounds and pounds and
pounds of adderall to all kinds of
people in in florida
and i would imagine and because matt
gatz was on his venmo uh this guy is
going to go seek
he was he took a plea deal outside the
grand jury so here's what normally
happens when you're in big trouble with
the feds they go to a grand jury to
charge you right and then the grand jury
seeks an indictment they get the
indictment they secure the indictment
then they arraign you
right they'll serve the warren whatever
it is now sometimes you self-surrender
sometimes they arrest your dumbass
so um
so so they they didn't seek an
indictment on this person though this
helicop this ellicott came in and pled
guilty to charges without an indictment
um what that means is now this person
ellicott who is selling adderall to not
matt gatz wink
um
[Laughter]
over vidmo this [ __ ] venmo [ __ ]
venmo's got to be like ah god damn this
[ __ ] matt gats case
you know
i don't know maybe it's maybe maybe you
know the whole good press bad press it's
all press thing but anyways
so this person pleads guilty to to
dealing adderall on venmo
and taking payments on venmo but also
he's going to go talk to the grand jury
and give deposition to the grand jury
which is not good for matt gatz and the
reason why it's not good for maggots you
think oh well joe greenberg you know
this guy's tight well joe greenberg has
already pled guilty
he's already played he's got his plea
deal in his pocket it's sealed it's in
his pocket all he has to do is keep
cooperating that's all he has to do keep
producing receipts and keep cooperating
that plea deal will be good he'll be
good on that plea deal which likely
likely
even with the plea deal this that just
joel greenberg is going to receive
anywhere between 10 and 15 years in a
federal prison and it's not going to be
a schwanky camp fed
this guy's going to go probably to a
goddamn a low or a medium
or or a or a chomo facility in
particular just because he's a sex
trafficker that's because he has those
charges the same way with matt gatz when
he gets indicted charged and sentenced
because matt gatz is gonna take a deal
that's that's that's what happens
the all of them take they don't go to
court normally 98 of the time
in a federal case
someone takes a deal because generally
speaking the feds if they're gonna bring
a grand jury
in and indict you with a grand jury
indictment especially they pile
superseding indictments on your dumb ass
then
you're [ __ ]
and matt gatz is [ __ ] he's [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] capital f [ __ ] his middle name
might as well be [ __ ] here
so good luck to matt gatz i really
um wish him the best um news yesterday
also um the magistrate judge in texas
orders oath keeper leader stuart rhodes
detained pending trial um so he will be
detained he will not be out on some sort
of arrest or under the custody of
someone uh whether it be pre-trial or
not uh his pre-trial
is detention
before he seeks trial now they uh his
lawyer you remember the reports why it
took the judge you know a couple day or
two
to release this actual
uh this this decision
because they were in court a couple days
ago and and i think it was like a
two-hour hearing
they went around and around around about
this about that detaining this guy this
[ __ ] seditionist
that's treason as [ __ ]
um they talked about you know whether
they were going to detain him or release
him whatever it was but here's the thing
here's the thing
if you if you
look at
what happened
to the oath keepers in texas right we've
seen a lady who's running for the house
the state legislator the house of texas
i i believe her name is kelly so real
jesus she can't make this [ __ ] up
her name is is kelly so real oh [ __ ]
she's so real right
oh god damn
apparently she took over as the
president of the oath keepers took the
mantle
from mr stewart rhodes when he was
charged with seditious conspiracy
and now that he's gonna be detained well
the thing is
i guess it's his girlfriend or something
i don't know she lives with him
something like that i can't [ __ ]
figure this out
right
so not only do you have do you have the
seditious conspiracist conspiratorist
going to be detained
uh and then then i don't know what the
situation is going to be with him uh
testifying before the january 6th select
company because you remember that that's
the reason why the judge the the federal
magistrate judge in texas right here
that that issued this order
right
that issue this order to be detained
took her 24 to 48 hours to make this
decision the reason why is because the
lawyers of student roads claim
that he's going to be
uh
appearing before the january 6 select
committee on february 2nd
now i rather that still happens or not
with his detention on february 2nd i'm
sure that the january 6 select committee
will figure out a way to depose this
person uh when he's in detention rather
that be you know via skype or some [ __ ]
like that
so i'm sure that's what it'll be here's
another um let's go back and give credit
here to kyle i forgot to give credit to
kyle here
if we read it we give credit okay
again here's this picture scott
reporting the same thing uh but you
gotta remember this guy you remember
this guy
you'll remember this guy and scott says
the same thing uh basically federal
judge
order stewart rose to be tamed
detained in jail pending trial and
seditious conspiracy case now likely
likely this this case is going to have
uh superseding indictments
so that's probably what is gonna happen
okay um hey did you guys know that
walter was off twitter for a while i
don't know what the problem was but
walters was off twitter walter's back on
um he has this really funny video
about wokeness and democrats
stepping on their own toes
um yeah you know
and we're always framing this up but you
guys want to watch this video from
walter you guys want to watch walter's
video
i want to watch walters video let's
watch walter's video on how democrats
step on their own twos what
you ready
like they just can't [ __ ] have a set
of nuts is kind of what he's saying but
listen
i lost the election because i was too
woke well i'm woke and i had no problem
winning my election i never should have
defunded the police you never defunded
the police
my opponent said i defunded the police
your opponent was lying so i never
defunded the police yeah you actually
voted to increase police funding it was
awkward
by the way i never should have taught
critical race theory in schools you
never talk critical race theory in
schools but my po
but wait
i did tweet that maya angelou is my
favorite author reading maya angelou is
not critical race theory
it's not it's just so unfair my opponent
painted me as this big leftist but
progressives hate me because i don't do
anything for them
yeah so why do you think you lost the
election
thank you walter i'm glad he's back on
twitter i don't know why he lost his
account but he's back on twitter so no
worries go over and and follow walter
let's see oh federal society was uh was
trending yesterday federal society can
eat a big bag of dicks
big bags big ass bags of dicks [ __ ] the
federal society
well let's see what else we got here
hey dude uh oh yeah you guys seen the
news yesterday um and that's why susan
collins is losing her mind so let's go
to the tree tweets in the trendy trends
let's see what's happening let's see if
anything's changed uh we got number
looks like number eight well let's see
here we got number eight we got um the
biden boom
biden boom
you guys heard that the economy grew at
the fastest rate since 1984 last year
the best year since
1984.
uh let's see
see if we can find uh what does minus
touch i have to say here in 2021 the u.s
economy grew at the fastest rate since
1984 we should all be tweeting this over
and over and saying it saying it out
loud best goddamn economy we've ever had
since ronald reagan got it
invoke that name
since ronald reagan
since ronald reagan has the economy
never been better i mean jesus christ
joe biden might as well be 1984 ronald
reagan right
really [ __ ] with them really dig in
there a bit
[ __ ] them uh amy lynn one of our
favorites says the us economy in 2021
has grown the fastest rate since the
reagan administration biden boom
uh who who's who's gonna tweet their
biden boom today huh
get in on the biden boom hashtag let's
see what else we got here uh here's
grant
retweeting nancy pelosi this is how most
americans judge a successful presidency
yeah like you would say oh well you know
most of the time when the economy's good
and maybe the president's doing a good
job too
you wouldn't say the opposite
[ __ ] boneheads
okay let's see what let's see what nancy
pelosi has to say here in our first year
president biden the democratic
majorities delivered the strongest u.s
economy since 1984 we must keep building
back better to make more progress in
people's lives so that all can reach
their fulfillment
okay i'm down with that
long messaging just to say we've had the
fastest growth since 1984 since ronald
reagan
but okay
um and sometimes the problem there right
okay let's go back to the uh
well
here we go lincoln watchman and it says
the u.s economy grew 6.9 percent last
quarter wow
biden boom
biden boom democrats democrats are the
only ones that deliver the economy
economy they deliver they're the only
ones to deliver on everything
republicans are helping on destroying
[ __ ] everything they want to destroy
democracy they want to destroy the
[ __ ] economy they want to they want
to destroy your [ __ ] health care they
want to destroy [ __ ] everything
they want they want to destroy the
healthcare system for [ __ ] sake
they're trying to make it to where
hospitals don't even have hospital beds
by encouraging people to do the things
that they don't that they should do
to make sure that our hospitals aren't
stuffed full of patients who are sick
from covid a simple [ __ ] vaccine will
take care of that
and they're brainwashing people
to get that
to make sure that the hospitals are
stuffed and packed full
let's see what else do we have here
mayo one of our favorite republicans
hate the fact that president biden has a
successful economy oh yeah it pisses
them off that's why they [ __ ] about gas
prices they're like oh gas prices even
though it like goes up seasonally and
then it goes down seasonally gas prices
milk milk milk
it's [ __ ] really dumb um look the
economy isn't where it needs to be for
sure
it isn't where it needs to be wages
aren't where they need to be uh health
care is definitely not where it needs to
be
but we're we're in the right direction
when we're with democrats
i mean republicans want to destroy all
this stuff i mean look look look what
happened with all the tariffs
and how it caused the price of [ __ ]
building materials to skyrocket in 2020.
the price of lumber skyrocketed in 2020
not under [ __ ] biting biden wasn't
president in 2020
it was trump that skyrocketed [ __ ]
building prices do you want to know why
housing costs went up you want to know
why trump that's why
that's why because of tariffs because he
thought it was some [ __ ] genius idea
for us to pay taxes on material that was
coming from
from other countries to here
for us to pay the taxes he thought he
was punishing
the [ __ ] the exporters but he was
punishing us
and it's still punishing us
and despite that despite that the
american people there's high demand in
the economy they're ready to spend money
and they're ready to get the economy
going again because democrats are doing
the things that people want them to do
to make sure that they can deliver on
the economy like roads bridges rule
[ __ ] internet
there's people in this country that
don't even have decent [ __ ] internet
it's 2022.
and we we we can't even get people
decent [ __ ] internet
come on give me a [ __ ] break with
this [ __ ] okay let's see well i mean
democrats will do it democrats did do it
democrats voted for that [ __ ] and
republicans are running around the
country like yay we got yay we got
high-speed internet in your area for you
even though i voted against it and was
diametrically opposed to it while it was
going through the house
i actually tried to stall it i tried to
stop you from getting real internet but
i'm so glad it's here and i want to take
credit please give me credit please give
me credit [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] them let's see here
um
of course you know it's a lot of
graphics here you guys should just go
look at the bite and boom thing just go
look at it just go look and see
just go look and see
it's there
and the great part is is they can't hide
from it like it's not something they can
[ __ ] you know they're going to be
like oh gasps
they're going to be standing at the pump
buying gas with their money that they
have oh
oh i'm spending money yeah it's called
the economy dumb [ __ ] okay let's see
susan collins you want to get into the
susan collins thread
we should do the susan collins thread
here
we should do this soon
ducks can resist too says
does anyone else think susan collins can
take her concerns and shove him up her
ass
after rushing through amy comey comey
barrett
and voting to confirm kavanagh she can
shut the [ __ ] up abso [ __ ] lutely
maine are you are you seeing the mistake
you made now are you seeing it
it's ridiculous
just all the [ __ ] nonsense coming out
of susan collins mouth this entire time
it'll never stop either she'll always be
like oh well they learned their lesson
oh
i must have learned my lesson when i
voted for the sexual harasser who cries
in his beer
for the federalist
for the woman who doesn't want women to
have liberty and they're only and she's
bought and paid for and the only reason
why she's here is because they jammed
her through the senate they even carved
out the filibuster just to make it work
can't even carve out [ __ ] filibuster
for goddamn voting rights in this
country get the [ __ ] out of here with
this [ __ ] susan collins
pound sand
take a [ __ ] hike
jesus okay let's see what else is there
is there a screenshot what does elgin
have to say
never forget susan collins was a
deciding vote for brett kavanaugh she
needs to sit
to set her concerned arse down somewhere
i think that's the sentiment today
susan collins needs to sit
you need to sit
and shut the [ __ ] up
uh let's see here
okay here don you know you guys know me
and don have been at it but but every
once in a while i like don i like his
videos all right
susan collins continues her quiet evil
march to mitch mcconnell's heart
i'll give you some credit don't
disappoint me non recount he's got
recounts video here it says this time
there is no need for any rush we can
take our time have hearings go through
the process it is a lifetime appointment
after all
oh geez
yeah jeez
let's listen as you know i know that the
timetable for the last nominee
was to compress yeah but yeah yeah right
but you did nothing you [ __ ] did
nothing about it
um
this time there is no need for any rush
we can take our time have hearings go
through the process
which is very important one it is a
lifetime
appointment after all as you know i felt
that at the time
oh
well everyone in the last several weeks
has been hating on
senator cinema and mansion well there's
a new one there's a new one you got to
deal with now
[Laughter]
mayo says susan collins is full of [ __ ]
yep absolutely 100 percent full of [ __ ]
you know why that is is because she's a
republican she's full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that's a [ __ ] requirement
that's a requirement
uh
let's see
what else we got here
what else do we have here
in the susan collins thread i want some
good jokes here
uh here you go joe uh in a comment
thread
and he says susan collins as you know i
felt that the timetable of the last
nominee was to compress this time
there's no need to rush
we can take blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah lifetime appointment after all
just what we just what we were what we
seen in the video
but you'll respond here by saying
susan's collin's going to see some
collin sheesh
ninka poops go to nincompoop you are
right joe all right let's see what else
we got here
oh in the season collins
oh caleb look you're in that you're in
the trendy trends
let's see oh this is this oh yes yes
russell honoree says
holy doo-doo here we go again senator
susan collins taking the center stage at
the scotus nomination she wants to slow
down the
the nomination lordy lordy
good thing she only has one vote
will give her more time more time to
vote
yep
crazy crazy crazy [ __ ] what did you say
caitlyn you said them
pass my message along to senator collins
who is fine with
with justice i like beer and sexual
assault
quotes
and justice handmade
being rammed through
hit the bit bricks [ __ ]
oh
oh my gosh
now
of course kalyn goes on a tirade here
thank you caitlyn for the tirade
everyone should go
read it oh here here's another one
there's no one how strong was the head
shaking on this
that bad huh susan collins needs to sit
the [ __ ] down after pushing through the
normal process to vote for justice i
like beer and just as handmade yes
she wasn't she wasn't a
i was opposed to it then even though i
voted for it even though i pushed it
through
susan collins apparently doesn't learn
her lesson uh let's see what else we got
um
i mean i guess this consensus this is
[ __ ] susan collins really honestly
here's the thing what the [ __ ] we don't
you know the filibuster is carved out
for supreme court justices now right
and kaitlyn says she was very concerned
she was very concerned
we don't have the fill of the buster the
good news is because of the republicans
i mean that's the good news with amy
coney barrett here
is we don't have the filibuster
also all we have to do
alls we have to do
is just
is just ram it through
like next week we could have this done
in 10 [ __ ] days just like they did
amy coney barrett
biden could nominate someone the
senators could have some kind of sham
[ __ ] committee hearing
get her to the floor
vote for her boom she's a supreme court
justice it doesn't take more than 10
days i mean the republicans prove that
to us it doesn't take more than 10 days
to make sure to get a supreme court
justice
especially if it's bought and paid for
i mean biden's already said he's gonna
he's gonna pick a black woman he made
that promise to make sure the diversity
was on the court
and everyone's like oh he's gonna he's
gonna pick her because of her race
well i mean she's a woman
and he wants diversity on the court he
he feels that the american people
deserve that the court
look like they look
has the the the actual diversity that
america has i mean so so
if it's about race it's because you guys
are butt hurt because it's a black woman
what's what's the big deal i mean if
biden promised that he was gonna pick a
white man would you be like oh it's all
about race it's all about race no
because it's a white man a white sweaty
ball sack
frankly i think we should put only women
on the supreme court it should be a
[ __ ] requirement they have [ __ ]
empathy
not like these that [ __ ] [ __ ] box
gorsuch who couldn't even put a piece of
cloth over his [ __ ] face to protect
the other supreme court justice
after it was requested by the chief
justice john roberts
yeah yeah do i think it should be a
requirement that it's only women abso
[ __ ] lutely
maybe we should only make federal judges
women
i don't know i'm just saying
let's do that
i'm i'm for it
the quicker we get to women actually
having the reigns of power in this
country and running this [ __ ] we're in
big trouble cause men have [ __ ] this
thing up royally and will continue
but when you have this
dumbass like susan collins placating to
these [ __ ] men
that's the problem that we got that's
the problem that we got okay let's go
down uh president pelosi
here we go speaking of republicans not
understanding how process works
nikki haley here
decides it's it's a good idea to
ask i mean she she really makes a great
case too
really makes a really great case i don't
know if she's asking the president to
resign because disney decided to draw
minnie with a pant suit or not i'm not
sure the exact reason but i'm sure it's
just as pressing of an issue of why the
president should resign it probably
really is like presidential type [ __ ]
you know like making decisions in
ukraine versus russia which you know
because biden biden should just be able
to not let russia
do war right that's the thing that
happens
in the world like we get to decide as
americans people really are [ __ ]
boneheaded to think that a president no
matter who it is gets to control what
other people are doing
and if you're if you're not [ __ ]
awake enough and been awake enough long
been awake long enough to realize that
putin is testing joe biden because he
didn't have to test donald trump
he didn't have to test donald trump to
see if donald trump would let him do
whatever the [ __ ] he wanted to do
he didn't have to he knew that [ __ ]
would bend over
he doesn't he doesn't know how biden's
going to react to him so he's got to
test him
china's got to test him too here to see
how far they can push him
if he'll actually do what he says he's
going to do they knew they knew trump
would gave they had no no [ __ ] no
[ __ ] question rather trump would gave
right in his back [ __ ] pocket putin
had him
why would he test trump but he's gonna
test he's gonna test biden here
and we're gonna see if diplomacy is
gonna win out i believe there's gonna be
some sort of conflict
but hopefully in the long run diplomacy
can win this one that's the last thing
that the american people want or need is
a hot war especially in ukraine
avenger resistors says nikki haley wants
joe biden and kamala harris to step down
[Laughter]
nikki haley please meet
president nancy pelosi you know they say
these things
they say these things and they're not
aware of like what they're saying
or they are aware of what they're saying
and they don't give a [ __ ] just like
they're complaining about minnie mouse
we're gonna get the [ __ ] minnie mouse
don't worry
let's see here um
is this where she's calling for it i'm
not even going to play this clip from
guy benson
uh josh has this um
is his quote tweeting i'll i'll give him
credit because he's alternate headline
nikki haley supports president biden
if biden loved our country he would step
down
and take kamala with him
this is really [ __ ] bone in it if you
guys want to go watch this clip i ain't
gonna play this [ __ ] idiot
i ain't gonna play this [ __ ] idiot
not this morning okay uh what's amy say
uh super genius nikki haley wants biting
to resign and take kamala harris with
him i don't think she's thought of this
through because it would mean president
pelosi good good thought process
i mean again and they're not thinking
they're not thinking back up about past
you know riling up their base see this
is this is the kind of [ __ ] that that
rachel's talking about with strategic
outrage right like this is how they do
it like it's right in front of you what
she's doing right
like here's the here's the [ __ ]
here's the tweet i guess
is this it
yeah here it is here's the [ __ ] tweet
if joe biden loved our country what
if joe biden loved our country the [ __ ]
out of here he would step down and take
kamala harris with him because the
foreign and domestic policy situation is
beyond dangerous at this point see this
is what they do
this is what they do right here
right what is she talking about
number one
what the [ __ ] is she talking about
this is what republicans do that
democrats need to do
this is the strategic outrage
what the [ __ ] is she talking about here
joe biden loves his country
we all know that he loves his country
step down and take kamala harris with
him well we know that would mean
president pelosi boy that pissed some
people off but she knows these [ __ ]
idiots that are going to eat up this
[ __ ] tweet that love this tweet they
don't know that they don't [ __ ] know
that
because foreign and domestic policy
situation what the [ __ ] does that mean
born in policy
what
what are you talking about you mean like
you mean like getting getting through
the pandemic trying to lift the economy
out of the pandemic
you mean that
domestic pot were we where we had a bite
and bloom
6.9 percent growth in the last quarter
the biggest growth since 1984 you mean
that domestic policy situation
so nikki haley here is saying that the
having a good economy in the best growth
since 1984 is bad for the american
people and the reason why it's bad for
the american people is because it shows
that joe biden loves his country
and not only that joe biden loves his
country he knows what the [ __ ] he's
doing
huh
who'd have guessed it
it's beyond dangerous at this point see
and this is the fear that's the fear
that's the fear that they really drive
in
take notes on this tweet
this tweet sucks because it's full of a
bunch of [ __ ] lies
but you can do tweets like this you can
write tweets like this with the [ __ ]
truth
and you can you can create strategic
outrage like she's doing here with lies
and [ __ ] you can do it with the
truth
your tweet oh that god damn it see i'm
getting in the habit [ __ ] that [ __ ]
your tweet sucks
i accidentally retweeted did you see
that i'm just clicking buttons here
okay here's the here's the regular daily
thing
your tweet sucks featured on the [ __ ]
list roundup
do you want to edit it it's offensive
offensive language which part is
offensive is it the tweet sucks part i
still haven't figured this out or is it
just the word [ __ ]
you guys know i don't know tweet that
[ __ ]
yeah but i don't know i i accidentally
retweeted her i apologize for that i
apologize
we apologize here when when we do things
wrong uh kevin here says who had nikki
haley angling for president pelosi on
their bingo cards
again again she's doing strategic
outrage is what she's doing here
that's what this is that's what the [ __ ]
this is that's what rachel's been
talking about
like she's not talking about anything
right here nothing absolutely [ __ ]
nothing
she doesn't say a specific policy
because if she said a specific policy
then then then it would be even
even more
smoked out is [ __ ]
everyone would know it's horse [ __ ] even
the people who love this tweet
right
we can do this
we can [ __ ] do this
and we can do this with the truth
[ __ ] nikki haley the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] okay let's let's move on
and see
of course everyone's putting up the uh
the
badass pelosi
[Laughter]
gifts
okay
let's see
all right let's see what else is in the
trendy trends and the tweety tweets
i'm tired of [ __ ] knocking on nikki
haley here
uh
megan mccain i don't know if this is the
megan mccain one or not
uh but megan mccain was trending earlier
for the view it doesn't look like this
is the megan mccain thread
maybe we'll find the megan mccain thread
we're 55 minutes into the first hour you
know we do two hours here every single
day
every single day
two hours
uh there's the minnie mouse
thread we'll get into that
let's see what else we got a geraldo
rivera
voices his support for neil young maybe
we'll get to that in the second hour uh
clarence thomas
is on the [ __ ] list today maybe we'll
make make him in the second hour
let's see what else do we have i forgot
uh what's our list yeah we got geraldo
candace owens tucker carlson
spotify we gotta do clarence thomas we
got all kinds of stuff to go through
joe rohan what
joe rohan is this supposed to be rogan
is twitter like uh
misspelling now i don't know marjorie
taylor green neon ah that sounds from
that sounds and peach biting
impeach him for the best economy since
1984. impeach him we don't want a good
economy if we he has a good economy he
may get re-elected democrats may win in
2022. we can't have this [ __ ] we're
fascist god damn it we need a fascist
state we need to impeach biden now for
having a good economy doesn't he know
that that a democratic president is
supposed to have a bad economy so we can
run against him having a bat get the
[ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you people talking
about
all right
let's go to a break and we'll come back
to the second hour and we'll go we'll go
through the impeach biden the candace
owens the minnie mouse [ __ ]
stick around we'll be we'll be right
back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babel maga
edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon i was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that i'm struggling with i
chose babble mag edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now i can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
[ __ ] em [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
i think you're hanging in with a break
here
[Music]
from all the ranting and raving
what what's thread you guys want to go
to next huh you want to go to uh you
want you want to go do the minnie mouse
thing i that's probably going to be like
25 30 minutes i know it's going to be it
has to be how am i not going to do 30
minutes on candace owens talking about
how she thinks minnie mouse
is
not sexy or so i don't know what the
[ __ ] she's saying we're gonna go watch
the clip we're gonna watch the clip
that's gonna be at least 25 30 minutes i
know it
i know myself
everyone's talking here about um
i guess oh chris chris here is chris
here is um
chris chris in you you uh let's see he
says donate away tony puts in the time
buy a hat while you're right yeah yeah
donate away put it in chris's name chris
chris is our hate watcher here we we
like chris coming and hate watching and
dropping the comments everyone likes
talking to chris
in the chat
thanks chris thanks chris for all the
all the all the things you do to pump
the algorithm and make sure that the
videos you know are out there by
commenting and coming and chatting and
we really appreciate having you uh mj
hey mj damn so late but here what's up
[ __ ] army we're about to do the
minnie mouse about to go into the minnie
mouse thread uh in the [ __ ] list roundup
so you just made it just in time for the
second hour
because i i think i think we're gonna do
the minnie mouse candace owens [ __ ]
first
i think that's what we'll do and then
we'll wrap it up with some other stuff
but before we do that i do want to i do
want to make a a couple
business stops here again we're on two
hours every single day
you know you normally with the [ __ ] list
roundup we'd stop right now right it
would be over but it's not we got a
whole other hour left because we do two
hours every single day weekday noon
eastern 11 central we go through the
tweety tweets and trendy trends and then
we're gonna have different people on uh
yesterday we had gabe and rachel
bitkoffer on both of them both of them
are on it was a great uh it was a great
conversation with rachel we're gonna try
to have her back every week or a week or
two um just to reiterate
and make sure we catch up on messaging
and what the election is because these
midterms are going to start to move
pretty fast as we get into the primary
season
here um the primary election cycle has
really begun
and once we get into it and then once
those primaries start to happen we'll
have a clear view of what that field of
candidates is going to look like for
2022
and how how how to make sure that we
keep the majority in the house and the
senate
now where to put your money where to put
your support
you know who's going to be in your
district
i mean that that's all going to be
important stuff also the down battle
races are going to be important too
after these primaries
we're going to see races uh that are
going to start to form out like georgia
uh texas arkansas is a very interesting
race there's a lot of diverse candidates
running down in arkansas one of the most
diverse democratic tickets that's ever
happened in the state of arkansas
i i think that could be a big change i
think a lot of these states are blue
they're not red they think they're red
that's why they vote red you get enough
people out you pile these people in
mountains of votes uh people that people
who want who want actual democracy
and who understand that democracy's at
stake
i believe a lot of these states are
going to turn blue they can if the
pro-democracy people would get out and
have their voices heard and let these
[ __ ] fascists know
that democracy is what they want they
don't want fascism they want democracy
you know forget about party forget about
party i mean there's only one the
problem is we have two parties in this
country and and and one only one prior
party at this point is pro-democracy
the other one wants nothing to do with
democracy they actually want to destroy
democracy democrats are the only ones
willing to deliver democracy to the
voters
i think there's going to be big backlash
against these republicans for not being
for voting rights
i think people are going to crawl over
hot [ __ ] lava to vote
i think that's what they're going to do
because we got to stay pissed and we
have to go [ __ ] vote but we have to
get engaged
so we're going to try to have rachel on
um to keep us up up to speed with what
these races look like as they form
uh so hopefully we'll have her back
every week or two um just have a
conversation like we did yesterday but i
put that conversation up on the youtube
channel uh
for you guys to watch so subscribe to
the youtube channel
and turn on the notifications the bell
notification
to make sure that when when i post
videos
uh outside of the podcast here that you
guys see those because not only not only
do we uh we we we're gonna do the two
hour show now uh every single weekday
noon eastern 11 central it's the podcast
now as opposed to wednesday afternoons
and then doing the [ __ ] list roundup
separate it's all one show uh we do
bonehead of the week on friday and i
actually last week what i did was i just
cut the bonehead of the week that we did
on friday and i re-aired it
on sunday so like you can watch it now
on youtube just that part
right and then the other thing too is i
i took the i took the interview
and we we cut the interview as a
separate piece and we aired that on
saturday that was the jeremy london
interview you guys know jeremy london
from mall rats
so that that's over there on youtube too
so go go watch those interviews and
watch the clip of
of rachel yesterday talking about
strategic outrage because we're going to
keep we're going to keep having her on
talking about that
and speaking of interviews uh we
recorded an interview with missy modell
she's a satirical
musician she does a lot of parody songs
they're [ __ ] phenomenal and fantastic
you gotta go watch her on tick tock
she's also on on on twitter
just follow missy modell
m-o-d-e-l-l missy modell
looks like we're gonna have that
interview ready for monday we would play
it tomorrow but we're going to do
bonehead of the week in the second hour
so we're going to play that interview on
monday for you and we got some other
guests that we're going to try to record
some other tweeters
that's right we're going to have some
people here on twitter that you know
supposed to record some interviews with
them
see what they think and play some trivia
with them so that's the thing about the
interviews now because we used to have
an interview like every wednesday but
now that the shows every single day two
hours a day we'll just record these
interviews and as we get them ready in
post and as they're ready to play then
we'll just we'll just plug them in we'll
just plug them in so there's no
set amount that we have so we might do
one interview a week we might do two or
three interviews a week it just depends
on how many guests how how our recording
schedule is uh for those extended
interviews but we're still gonna do the
pop-ins i know you guys want po poc back
we've been trying to schedule our
schedules did not meet again today
but we'll get it we'll get him back i'm
strong arnold and he owes us he owes us
big time here on the tony michael's pod
so we'll get him back we'll get him back
so don't forget again to subscribe to
the youtube channel and we don't miss
any of that stuff that comes down the
pike
you don't want to miss any of that stuff
no matter what it is whether it's the
pop-ins whether it's the [ __ ] list or
the the the bonehead of the week
or it's rachel cummings talking about
strategic outrage or the interviews you
do not want to miss it okay let's get
back to the trendy trends and the tweety
tweets here um candace owens is trending
of course and minnie mouse was trending
earlier uh let's see let's go to the
trendy trends and see
let's see let's see what the uh what the
numbers say here
if minnie mouse is still trending or if
it's just yep minnie mouse are training
at number 24.
number 24 minnie mouse when i seen this
this morning oh
there's disney is doing something
well
they did something
disney paris
designed
minnie mouse in the first pants suit
that's this this is what they're pissed
off about
this is it this is the [ __ ] picture
that they're [ __ ] furious about this
is the culture war they're gonna stoke
the crt culture war the crt voodoo
because they drew her in a pant suit
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
it's crazy ass [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you people talking
about
um
let's let's go to the uh
well here
letitia has has this here oh look
there's mini and pants somehow not
destroying the fabric of society
just being an adorable cartoon mouse as
one does
this is the really weird
weird [ __ ] thing about this too is
like
you know the the eminem candy thing they
were obsessed about how sexy it was or
it wasn't right
like whatever the [ __ ] that was supposed
to be about
and if you go back and listen to the
tape of tucker carlson and i said it the
other day he says the word transition
right that's what he said he says
transition
from high heels to tennis shoes as if as
if a [ __ ] woman can't wear tennis
shoes in the fir get the [ __ ] out of
here or be sexy in a pair of tennis
shoes i've seen plenty of women that are
plenty sexy in a pair of tennis shoes
he's got his [ __ ] mind all twisted up
that you have to wear sexy heels to be
sexy get out of here
but the problem is the problem is is
that these people they're they're making
this tart cartoon [ __ ] these cartoon
drawings where where they have certain
clothes or certain shoes or they're not
sexy enough or they're too sexy or
whatever the [ __ ] it is that they're
doing
the word transition really works its way
in you notice that i i mentioned that
the other day on the tucker carlson
tirade that i went on about him wanting
to [ __ ] the m m's because it's here
here's the deal
if if tucker carlson that white fragile
male walked into a bar and saw really
sexy eminem i mean hot smoking [ __ ]
hot smoke show eminem [ __ ] high heels
makeup oh my god this eminem was the
eminem's of eminem's
he hid on her bought her drinks flirted
with her finally he was able to take her
home with him and then when he got home
he discovered that she transitioned in
the tennis shoes
and she wasn't she wasn't the sexy
eminem she was supposed to be you follow
me you follow me there this is about
this is about trans people that's what
it's about it's they're trying to make
this [ __ ] a sexual culture war
with people who don't give a [ __ ]
the majority of americans don't give a
[ __ ] who other people are [ __ ] as
long as it's consensual
andrea's here what's up
we're talking about minnie mouse
look
this is this is what they're trying to
do
is trying to place this word transition
and trying to scare their [ __ ]
constituents to think that somehow
minnie mouse or or the
the female m m as if an m m can have a
gender jesus christ this is the same
[ __ ] with the mr and mrs potato head
that they lost their minds about
lost their [ __ ] minds
over a potato not having genitalia
potatoes don't have genitalia they don't
have it
it's an inanimate object
cartoons i guess if you draw it that way
it can have genitalia but minnie mouse
doesn't have it
eminem's the cartoons did they don't
have genitalia it's not a thing it's not
a thing
[ __ ] morons okay here's the [ __ ]
clip here's the clip i've heard of
candace owens because um you know the
eminem
the eminem thing was on tucker carlson
right now
jesse waters has to have candace owens
on now this is this is the really
[ __ ] crazy part
if you look at this screenshot here
look at what she's bitching about she's
bitching about this picture we showed
earlier where minnie mouse is in a
purple
suit
right she's in a purple suit
and why it's called a pant suit i have
no idea why in the [ __ ] can a woman just
wear a suit a dude just wear a suit when
a dude wears a suit it's not a pant suit
what the [ __ ] why does it have to be a
pant it's a [ __ ] suit she's got a
[ __ ] suit on
but if you look over here at the person
that's gonna [ __ ] about minnie mou
mouse destroying american society the
fabric of american society because she's
wearing a suit
this [ __ ] has got a suit on
she's got a [ __ ] purple suit look at
that
it's a [ __ ] purple suit
am i wrong am i [ __ ] wrong here
she's i mean other than the [ __ ] the
the polka dots on the suit she's
basically dressed the same way that
minnie mouse is here in the [ __ ]
picture that's drawn
so who's destroying the fabric of
society candace
the [ __ ] out of here with this fake ass
outrage this is the [ __ ] that they do
folks this is how they beat democrats
right here this is how they do it
i'm gonna take this banner down so you
can see the stupid [ __ ] on the screen
here too
there you go now you can see minnie
mouse swaps see that swaps
you got it you see the language they use
it's that transition language
swaps iconic red dress for pant suit
let's listen to this [ __ ] idiot
i mean look if this is why people don't
take these people seriously
wait wait are you talking about us
because we aren't we aren't concerned
about minnie mouse like the liberal woke
mob didn't go down to disney and like
hey you know what you got to do
[ __ ] you know what you gotta do
you gotta put minnie mouse in a pantsuit
and if you don't do it now what the [ __ ]
are you talking you are the ones the
reason why i'm talking about this [ __ ]
right now is because your dumbasses have
a problem with disney drawing their
cartoons in certain clothes
they're taking all of these things that
nobody was offended by yep you're taking
all these things that no one was
offended by it's like they have to get
rid of them and destroy them and you
want to cancel [ __ ] disney and minnie
mouse because they drew her with a pant
suit
the [ __ ] projection here is [ __ ]
ridiculous absolutely crazy you can't
even make this [ __ ] up
like literally this would be an snl skit
if you [ __ ] wrote it out
they are parroting themselves
because they're bored you know they're
absolutely bored they're trying to
destroy fabrics of our society
pretending that there's
they're bored
so we
who have to respond to your dumb ass
worried and distracting from biden
having the biggest [ __ ] economic boom
since 1984 because that's what they're
doing here folks they can't go on fox
news and be like oh my god joe biden had
the biggest [ __ ] economy boom since
1984. it's the best economy since the
reagan administration they can't do that
how in the [ __ ] would they do that they
can't do that they gotta find [ __ ] they
gotta [ __ ] find all kinds of [ __ ]
they gotta talk about how [ __ ] m m's
don't have sexy asses anymore minnie
mouse
she's not wearing a thong she's putting
on granny panties and wearing a pantsuit
what the [ __ ] are you people talking
about that we're obsessed and we're
[ __ ] bored you people are the ones
who are having it on your show
disney and paris
drew a cartoon that they own in a
pantsuit
and you people are so [ __ ] bored that
you're losing your minds
on fox news in a purple pants soup
[ __ ] me issues so everybody looks over
here look at minnie mouse don't look at
inflation jesse look look at minnie
mouse don't look at the biting economy
please don't look how successful the
biden economy is don't look how he's
trying to drag us out of a pandemic even
though we're trying to gaslight people
into not doing what they should do about
the pandemic to keep us to keep us in a
pandemic that way people remain sick and
our healthcare system remains strained
so we can blame it on biden we can blame
it on biden that evil biting making
minnie mouse wear a pant suit that
[ __ ]
also he's really sleepy and he can't get
out of bed and he probably can't even
put a sentence together look at minnie
mouse the world is going forward because
you've got her in a pantsuit never mind
that you can't get anything at the
grocery store and you can't buy a piece
of bacon unless you've got 30 dollars in
your pocket okay see this is the other
stupid [ __ ] see this is the other stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] that they do
you can't get anything at the grocery
store who in the [ __ ] is going to the
grocery store and there's empty shelves
i haven't been to one [ __ ]
grocery store with empty shelves have
you
and who the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] thinks
bacon is 30 dollars a [ __ ] piece of
bacon
who the who
someone who doesn't buy [ __ ] bacon
or who doesn't pay attention to the
grocery bill
definitely knows that a [ __ ] piece of
bacon isn't 30 bucks
purple pant suit
candace owens your pantsuit is
destroying the fabric of our society
stop it at least we're addressing the
real problem which is minnie mouse
that's right i mean
oh oh the dismount the [ __ ] the
dismount parody of herself there is
[ __ ] fantastic well let's oh my god
oh my god i want to cut this out i want
to cut this out and put it the music
somebody somebody please out there cut
this out and put it to me no problem
which is minnie mouse
at least we're addressing the real
problem which is minnie mouse
at least we're addressing the real
problem which is many many differences
in your pocket at least we're addressing
the real problem
30 dollars in your pocket at least we're
addressing the real problem which is
minnie mouse someone please get that do
you remember um back in let's see here's
2012 campaign remember this uh president
barack obama went to arizona i believe
and he was having a rally right
it was a political rally he was running
for president of the united states he
was the president of the united states
and he got on stage and he was talking
about roads and bridges and building
roads and bridges and you know
everyone's staying you know everyone's
calling him a socialist and all this
[ __ ]
and he was talking about how businesses
need the government to build things like
roads and bridges so that they have an
economy that the businesses can strive
in like the businesses out there private
business relies on the government to
create certain types of infrastructure
so that they can rely on that
infrastructure to to to do business so
that we can have a good economy that's
what he was talking about and when he
said it he said
uh
rhodes
if you got a business
you didn't build that
but they cut the roads part off right
and they said you got a business you
didn't build that do you remember that
do you remember that do you remember
when they cut that out and i mean they
pounded it they pounded it and they
pounded it and they pounded it because
it's a [ __ ] line it's [ __ ] stupid
they created all this outrage and
complete national outrage in republicans
because barack obama i mean i had
personal people tell me that he said
this i'm like yeah he did say those
words but you understand that that
that's not those words
and out of context sound like you want
them to sound but they really don't mean
what you think they mean like if you
went and watched the whole clip you'd
understand what the [ __ ] he was saying
all i'm saying all i'm saying here in
this case we definitely should not clip
out the part this part here
we should definitely not clip this part
out
we should definitely not clip this part
out always in your pocket at least we're
addressing the real problem which is
minnie mouse at least we're dressing the
real problem minnie mouse that's the
part so someone please don't cut that
part and loop it over and over and over
and over and over and over and over
again and make sure that everyone knows
that the real problem that probably
republicans have and the real issue that
republicans want to talk about because
it is an issue in this country you know
there's things like decent wages and dec
making sure you don't go bankrupt
because of health care um making making
sure that you're healthy and you're safe
you have a decent job you know all those
things a decent education having public
education decent public education for
your children all those things
roads bridges rule high-speed internet
all those things take second back seat
to minnie mouse the most important issue
in this country right now as we speak
and candace owens you heard her say it
right here you heard her say it your
pocket at least we're addressing the
real problem which is minnie mouse at
least we're addressing the real problem
minnie mouse
he's [ __ ] idiots
oh
what the hell are we gonna do
with these [ __ ] boneheads it's 19 19
minutes at in the second hour i told you
this thing was gonna be i told you i
told you it's gonna be at least 20 or 30
minutes
now let's see um
like literally look at these screenshots
from aaron
ward disease social breakdown political
gridlock minnie mouse wearing a pantsuit
this is it
and again you see the screenshot here
look it says swaps
swaps it's that transition language
that's that's why they're trying to tie
these cartoons
to to transgender because it really gets
them fired up you remember the bathroom
thing you know oh they love to have the
bathroom fight again they would love to
have the bathroom fight again this year
you know the bat you know these [ __ ]
weirdos are completely [ __ ] obsessed
with other people's [ __ ] genitalia in
the bathroom i have never and i don't
know about you but i've never went into
a bathroom to go take a piss or you know
number two
and was worried about other people's
genitalia in a bathroom especially in a
public bathroom i want to get in there
and get the [ __ ] out i'm not worried
about other people you [ __ ] weirdos
that are worried about other people's
genitalia in the bathroom you're the
[ __ ] weirdos you're the ones who are
weird
because you're [ __ ] worried about
what other people have in their pants
what are you doing go in the bathroom do
your [ __ ] business and get the [ __ ]
out don't what worry about what other
people have in their pants
[ __ ] weirdos
but here it is swaps that word swaps
it really is trying to take hold of that
language transition
that's it
um
veteran said don't make a joke about
scared of girls [ __ ] being bigger
[Laughter]
oh
andrea said the bathroom [ __ ] is twisted
as [ __ ] yeah it's really [ __ ] weird
it's really [ __ ] weird
that they are so worried about other
people's [ __ ] in a bathroom
you [ __ ] weirdos
but this screenshot was put up by aaron
um
but again he's saying here
that they're this is what they're
worried about i mean literally they're
they're cheering on a war
you see joe here says these freaks
really have a hell of a fetish for
[ __ ] cartoon animals
i mean it's something else
it's something else joe it is something
else
well again this isn't about the cartoon
this isn't about the pant suit this is
about them tying cartoon characters
to cancer culture and transgender people
they want that [ __ ] social war you
can see them trying to construct this
thing right you remember [ __ ] last
year when they were constructing the crt
thing for the yunkan race they were
constructing this whole crt thing for
the for the california recall and the
and the yunkan race this voodoo it's
[ __ ] voodoo no one was teaching white
white children to feel guilty they were
teaching them history actually most of
these schools were teaching [ __ ]
history so that white people don't feel
guilty like that's literally they
they're
don't don't stop teaching my kid not to
feel guilty white people who feel guilty
about history
is your problem that you feel guilty
you're the racist like when i hear
history
i'm like oh man that's shameful [ __ ]
that we did i don't feel guilty for it
i don't feel guilty
if you feel guilty when you hear history
it's probably a problem you have not a
problem that that black people have
black americans black people people of
color it's probably not that
the the critical race theory is is is
got you deluded and that's what this is
this is their new critical rate they
tried this uh you guys remember a couple
i think it's a month ago they tried this
mass formation psychosis remember this
this [ __ ] doctor this they claim he
created the vaccine which he did not
that's all a [ __ ] lie he's butt hurt
because millions of these vaccines are
being sold
and and none of them none of them and
none of that money is going to him
that's what he's [ __ ] butt hurt about
he went on joe rogan's show
and he said uh uh people who are taking
the vaccine and believing about the
vaccine is mass formation psychosis like
it was a total [ __ ] and and and jack
poissiak or whatever the [ __ ] that
fascist name is he's continuing with
this mass formation psychosis they're
trying to make that the next crt but fox
news is all in on the cartoon crt [ __ ]
the cartoon trans transphobic
transphobic
candy has to be sexy thing
they are terrified these white fragile
males like jesse waters and tucker
carlson are terrified that they would
find a woman who used to be a man
attractive they are terrified that that
woman's [ __ ] may be bigger than theirs
aaron is that good yoda is that what you
were looking for
[Laughter]
all right
aaron also post this screenshot look at
this minnie mouse and m m's have major
makeovers they are [ __ ] obsessed
obsessed with it oh my god they're
obsessed with the email lady like they
can't help but tie it back to email lady
right like wearing pantsuits is bad
okay well here's the thing candace owens
when have you ever seen her not in a
pant suit like literally
and again it's a suit it's a suit
i don't know
maybe i maybe i'm maybe i'm um
overstepping my bounds there
but it's a [ __ ] suit when a dude
wears it it's a suit
i don't know maybe i'm wrong am i wrong
i i don't know anything about fashion to
be quite honest with you all right let's
see what else we got
uh and joe appears in the trendy trends
all the time joe's one of our favorite
uh overhead today at school did you see
what they did to minnie
mouse the country is falling apart how
terrible what's next i can't even so sad
me it's a cartoon mouse and pants
did you guys even hear yourself
[Laughter]
oh sounds like uh
joe is having language around her that
they they watch fox news apparently
people around joe watch fox news last
night
oh here we go here's another one from
joe she's in the trend what am i gonna
do joe's one of my favorite accounts and
she's in the trend i gotta i gotta play
it's my show
pretending to be upset about minnie
mouse wearing pants is just plain goofy
happy thursday
all right well i'm going to uh admit
something here right on the show since
joe brings it up uh i i do a decent a
decent goofy well hey minnie are you
wearing a plant suit oh yeah i'm just
i'm just saying i'm just saying maybe we
could go
someone could do if you want a voiceover
for a sketch
gabe if you're listening out there if
you want to if you want a goofy if you
want a goofy
voiceover okay let's let's move on ah
here's another scary larry the same
party that insists democrats can't be
taken seriously is losing its [ __ ] over
green m m's heels and minnie mouse pants
suits and never fails
like they always they always pile this
[ __ ] on right you remember you remember
um
last year they were on the tirade about
you know potatoes not having genitalia
you remember the [ __ ] the mr potato head
missed potato and because all hasbro did
was bait these [ __ ] i think
they're like oh yeah these people are
totally gonna [ __ ] about this they're
totally gonna [ __ ] about about if we
change the [ __ ] gender of the potato
right
because it's mr potato head you can't
you can't take away the mister but but i
guess they just changed the box like it
just they took off the mister off the
top of the box and put potato head on it
and then and then
whether you were buying the mr or the
misses it set it down at the bottom
right so they're just changing the art
they've lost their [ __ ] minds for
months and then it was the dr seuss
thing all at the same time remember it
was dr seuss potato head dr seuss potato
head now they can't just have one
because it's so [ __ ] ridiculous they
can't just talk about how they want to
[ __ ] eminem's or they don't want to
[ __ ] m m's anymore because m m's
aren't sexy i guess that's a narrative
you know they're they're transitioning
right they're transitioning so m ms
aren't sexy anymore because they're
transitioning right
it's the language
but they gotta add in minnie miles so
it's not so ridiculous
[Laughter]
smite here says if republicans
republicans have been imagining having
sex with minnie mouse all this time
couldn't they just imagine her without
pants
that is true
that's that's the other weird [ __ ]
thing here right schmidt makes a good
point
i've never looked at minnie mouse i'm
like ooh
sexy
sexy minnie mouse like i didn't think
disney never really i don't think they
were drawing minnie mouse to be sexy do
you
i mean my assumption was is like minnie
mouse was a young girl
right like a young adult woman like
she's not she could possibly be a
teenager even possibly in some of those
cartoons some of the situations right
i don't know i'm just saying it's a
little on brand it's a little on brand
for these republicans to be
spotting out that minnie mouse is
dressed a certain way and she may look
a certain age
i don't know seems on brand me with all
this [ __ ] matt gats [ __ ] running
around
maybe they should venmo an artist
to draw up minnie mouse in a sexy
situation get the [ __ ] out of here with
this [ __ ]
okay let's see here that that damn
um
worth 29 minutes 30 minutes into the
hour see i told you we're going to do 30
minutes on minnie mouse i told you it's
going to be 30 minutes now here's
another clip what is this this seems
like a longer clip
it is a longer clip this is the lead up
oh i'm very interested in this let's go
watch this let's see what this is i have
some real news and i can't believe i'm
actually saying this candace but disney
i have some real news
this
real really this is it
they really are a [ __ ] parody look we
have here on the tony michaels podcast
we have a parody news network it's
called really news now i'm not [ __ ]
you we got a [ __ ] we got a [ __ ]
twitter account we've done a couple
videos uh the one show in particular
speaking of joe becky's shoe was on you
know the character that joe does becky
sue
mj says candace sucks well
her pant suit sucks here it's destroying
the fabric of society
she's wearing a [ __ ] pantsuit she's
wearing a suit she's wearing a suit
she couldn't just take oh my god
i forgot where i was at thanks mj
let's just watch the [ __ ] video
is totally changing minnie mouse disney
is putting minnie mouse
in a pantsuit that's right they're
getting rid of okay okay
there there is no indication that that
disney is changing minnie mouse these
people
oh you give them [ __ ] one goddamn
millimeter
one
one goddamn millimeter just one
just one oh andrea did she pointed out
where i was at
a parody news that's it that's it see
that's what i was talking about board mj
distracted me
saying candace sucks
thank you andrea
we'll get back to that
these people are believing they take
they give them a little bitty [ __ ]
nugget where this is one picture just
one [ __ ] drawing of minnie mouse in a
pantsuit
just one and all of a sudden disney's
changed the whole [ __ ] character made
her into a dude whatever they think
whatever the hell they're gonna say
whatever the hell they want to do right
because it's this swap transition talk
that they're focused they can't stop
focusing on other people's [ __ ] sex
lives like they just can't stop
but jesse waters thinks this is real
news
that disney has completely changed the
character which they did not
this is really [ __ ] dumb so back to
the the parody news account we actually
have parody news count if you go check
it out it's really news now
you can just you can search it
here i'll um um
i believe it's uh
i can't remember the [ __ ] handle
right now
it's really
yeah it's really news now here i'll type
it down
really news now
on twitter
there's the there's the handle
really news now on twitter
if you go over there and there's a there
might be a video
of carl carl tuckerson
show white privilege tonight it's over
there i'm just saying if you want to go
watch it skirt
and this is disney paris or something
like that
and i thought who better to ask about
this than candace owens you react who
better to ask about this than about a
mini being drawn in a purple pantsuit
than the person who appears on my show
about with a purple pantsuit what the
[ __ ]
why are they doing this oh i'm just so
glad i'm so glad they're doing this let
me just tell you jesse it's it goes back
to like when they did this to the m m's
and now they're making her more
masculine and i'm glad that they're now
saying realizing that this needed to be
addressed you know all of us were trauma
mj mj i wasn't tossing on the bus i'm
saying
what i'm saying is you distracted me
with the comment candace sucks and the
reason why is because i had another 15
minutes to do just on that comment but i
can't do it here on youtube i can't do
that kind of content here on youtube
thank you mg
but times when we saw minnie mouse
and she was looking like a female as we
were growing up i mean look at this is
why people don't take these people
seriously they're taking all of these
things that
nobody was offended by it's like they
have to get rid of them and destroy them
because they're bored you know they're
absolutely bored here's the dismount
there's issues so everybody looks over
here look at minnie mouse don't look at
inflation jesse look at minnie mouse
where the world is going forward because
you've got her in a pantsuit never mind
that you can't get anything at the
grocery store and you can't buy a piece
of bacon unless you've got 30 dollars in
your pocket at least we're addressing
the real problem which is minnie mouse
we're addressing the real problem which
is minnie mouse someone please cut that
[ __ ]
please please and put it on a loop to
some music or some [ __ ]
i'm telling you it'd be gold tick tock
gold over there okay let's see what else
do we have
we are 35 minutes see i told you we do
30 minutes on a mini oh oh here you go
here you go
minnie mouse is turning on twitter
because she's wearing a pantsuit as part
of disney paris's promotion and the news
of overreacting and acting like she
ain't gonna wear or dress no more bruh
bruh this literally ain't the first time
she looks
looks good really good in pantsuit look
at this okay there's that one oh there's
that one
it's not even a drawing they [ __ ]
made the pantsuit for her they made the
[ __ ] suit for her right they didn't
just draw it they [ __ ] made it and
minnie mouse still appears in the dress
you people really are [ __ ] boneheads
you really are [ __ ] boneheads
uh you know we we we
looks like matt gatz is gonna be the
dishonorable mention of the week for
bone end of the week tomorrow but oh
[ __ ]
oh here's another one so minnie mouse
and pants like here it is there's there
she is in pants again
and really honestly this drawing is a
hell of a lot more
salacious than than most drawings of
many
jesus christ
it's minnie mouse people it's [ __ ]
minnie mouse let's see if we can find
some more drawings of minnie mouse and
pantsuits
oh oh here you go
alex says so it's okay for candace wants
to wear fancies but not minnie mouse
come on candace what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] and it's not even a good
pantsuit at least they drew minnie in a
fashionable pant suit
jeez let's see i did do
there's a clip again let's see if
there's any more pictures
oh here you go here you go there you go
here's some more pictures if you're a
fan that is really deep into franchise
you would probably know that minnie
mouse is is fashion is fashion versatile
like literally they put her in all kinds
of clothes here's the overalls like i
was saying earlier overalls [ __ ]
gardening hat
and this looks like some sort of
superhero suit
look
it's a cartoon you [ __ ] idiots
they're going to draw her in all kinds
of costumes it's a [ __ ] cartoon
damn
uh here you go here's some more pictures
of minnie mouse
pants dresses all kinds of [ __ ] right
i can't believe i'm jumping into this
but minnie mouse has several different
costumes at every park and served as a
raging truly breaking news alert raging
because she got one more and it doesn't
require a bloomer
because that's the thing she wears
bloomers what about what about donald
duck donald duck doesn't even wear
[ __ ] pants how do these how does
canis owens feel about donald duck
not wearing pants that motherfucker's
running around with his duck dicks
hanging out right
she offended by that huh
maybe donald duck should put pants on is
that what she's gonna advocate for
disney needs to put pants on that
goddamn duck
jesus christ a duck running around
slinging that duck dick everywhere what
i mean are we we gonna do that is that
what we're gonna do jesus christ yeah
winnie the pooh yeah andrea winnie the
pooh does not does not [ __ ] does not
[ __ ] wear pants either
yoda says do not give them new ideas no
i i would love to clown them if they
were talking about duck dick come on
donald duck dick if they if they went on
fox news jesse waters or tucker carlson
was talking about donald duck dick you
don't think i could make [ __ ] 30
minutes out of that [ __ ]
hey oh let's see what else we got here
when a sparker say also the minnie mouse
story is even dumber than it being made
out to be on fox
it's not even a permanent change just a
one-off costume change for a single
event
yeah well let's see originally
uh her original tweet rather than write
a whole new one of these just fine
replacement green m m's with minnie
mouse that's right
they just rage
like the last person's saying just rage
about anything and just copy paste right
copy [ __ ] paste
and again it's the whole transition swap
chicks with dicks [ __ ] language
that's what they're doing that's the
language that they're using
oh you know they're
making into this whole [ __ ]
sexual thing
tucker carlson acts like he beats off
the m m's and [ __ ]
okay let's see here
oh here you go there you go
oh yeah oh so candace owens is so woke
about minnie mouse wearing a pantsuit
again
i guess rats with pants
suits feel threatened
oh [ __ ]
uh for you guys watch are listening on
the podcast this is candace owens
wearing a pantsuit standing next to
donald trump with this stupid [ __ ]
thumbs up i don't know why does he do
that thumbs up like thumb in the butt
thing i don't know why he does a thumbs
up thing it's like a reaction or
something so candace owens is woke about
i guess rats
oh [ __ ] god damn
people with the [ __ ] minnie mouse
jokes
thank you so much
it's a good thursday
oh let's see what else we got here
of course there's hundreds and hundreds
of pictures of minnie mouse and [ __ ]
in [ __ ] pants like you just roll down
this thread and there they are pants
pants pants she's in pants oh there
she's in pants oh there she's in another
costume oh look that's a different
costume oh look they drew in something
different here oh look there she is in
pants oh she looks completely different
in that drawing oh there's some pants
it really is [ __ ] dumb
it really is [ __ ] dumb i i'm not sure
what's [ __ ] more moronic
this [ __ ] minnie mouse can't wear
pants or or tucker carlson wants to have
sex with m m's it really is [ __ ]
weird okay let's see what else we're 40
minutes into the hour the second hour of
the [ __ ] list roundup
let's take a quick break
and we'll be right back after these
messages
you sit your ass down set the flip down
we're not finished the tony michaels
podcast we'll be right back
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess
well now there's boycott binder the
ingenious organizer that keeps track of
everything and everyone you've ever
boycotted the 72 category filing system
makes it easy to organize boycotted
people places and things so you can find
them with ease the large centered area
can even fit your boycott sign but best
of all when you're done the boycott
binder folds right up so you can take it
anywhere so if you're tired of having a
cluttered mess call now and get the
boycott binder for just 29.99
plus you'll also receive our next rep as
a bonus just loop it around your neck to
travel with ease but call right now and
we'll double the offer that's two
boycott binders and two neck straps for
just 29.99
boycott binders brought to you by the
same makers of binders full of women
the tony michaels podcast wednesdays at
4 p.m eastern 3 p.m central watch live
on youtube on twitter and twitch
download on apple and spotify now
[Music]
i guess i just keep missing it it's not
on wednesdays anymore
i really need to change that don't i oh
man fail big huge fail here on the tony
michaels podcast with the production i
promise that's not gabe's fault i'd
blame it on him if it was but it is not
gay's fault that is my fault i keep
playing that the wednesday uh sound we
are not on wednesdays anymore where are
we days
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central right here on youtube twitter
twitch how do you guys like the new
format how do you guys like having it at
the new time two hours a day what do you
guys think all you are you folks out
there in the comments
uh if if you're not in the comments live
go ahead go ahead and if you're watching
this afterwards leave us a comment down
below tell us how you like the new
format
uh you like the two hours give it give
us a shout out
on that and let us know how we're doing
over here um
minus robin hey robin says 100 mj gives
us fire and hearts
and caitlyn gives us a thumbs up all
right well you know it's some good
that's some good feedback
okay
we're gonna go to the trendy trends and
the tweety tweets again here we got
about uh 15 minutes left here in the
show and um there's one well i'm i'm
missing something here
uh oh the clarence thomas oh also the
the spotify and the the geraldo
uh veteran yoda says i love it no
productivity
oh well what happens it happens it
happens oh yeah mj says chris give us
feedback oh chris is here every day
i i could do six hours a day and chris
would watch the whole thing
loves to hate watch this loves it
loves it to hate watch this [ __ ]
yeah and chris stay with us
i like having chris here do you guys
like him and chris here hate watching we
need more hate watchers chris invite
your friends okay let's see here well
has this changed at all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends uh we got
something new on this is there's some
breaking news you know yesterday the the
actual um the supreme court justice
stephen breyer uh retiring was actual
breaking news
uh and and that was that was a big
a big deal um and it happened while we
were on the air
so we didn't get we we talked a lot
about it with gabe yesterday and i
actually posted the clip of us talking
about it on youtube again
uh we're going to post more i'm going to
try to post more clips over there so
like and subscribe
go follow all that stuff whatever it is
that you gotta do comment you know
whatever i'm supposed to say again that
the youtubers say
that the
the kings and queens of the tubes of you
whatever they say over there that just
get you to interact whatever that is i
don't know all right
um apple music is trending probably
because spotify is turning let's go do
that let's go do that little shtick here
uh you guys seen that neil young
if i can find it here is spotify not
trending anymore where the hell we go
uh neil young um basically told spotify
we talked about this yesterday
told them to go [ __ ] themselves either
pull joe rogan down or pull his music
off spotify
and um
what happened was is they pulled his
music off spotify
it looks like apple music is trending
because of it let's see
um
and that is the other subject of harald
though i guess geraldo was defending
neil young
to get apple music um
oh jack here says um here's what he says
spotify chose joe rogan over neil young
i'll choose apple music over spotify
okay well i'll retweet this but here's
here's my thoughts on it
and uh maybe jack can come watch my
thoughts on it here's my thought
okay
neil young has the complete and utter
right to tell spotify
to to pull his [ __ ] music down if
they're gonna keep joe rogan he has that
right and he should do that if he wants
to and really the neil young fans if if
they want to listen to neil young on a
different platform then they should go
to another platform and listen to neil
young
right that's how this works now as far
as joe rogan goes
here's the thing
i'm not getting off spotify i'm not
taking my content off spotify not gonna
happen
now neil young felt it to be his
prerogative to do that and he has the
right to do that i'm not gonna do it and
here's why
maybe maybe just maybe now he's got a
shitload bigger audience than me
um obviously and maybe maybe we can we
can chip away at it but listen if there
is someone that's going to talk the
opposite way that joe rogan talks on his
[ __ ] podcast on spotify i want them
there rather that's me or anyone else
so everyone leaving spotify because they
won't drop joe rogan and then there be
no voices on spotify to battle this
stupid [ __ ] propaganda this stupid
[ __ ] misinformation
then bam
they win they [ __ ] win now neil young
is not the same content as joe rogan
so again neil young has the absolutely
100 right to take his content down off
spotify and he should do that if he sees
fit fine i'm i'm for neil young in that
way
but i'm not taking my [ __ ] down
i'm not taking my [ __ ] down and i'm not
saying boycott spotify what i'm saying
is you know what you should do you
should go to [ __ ] spotify and you
should download my podcast 100 [ __ ]
times that's what you should do you
should go download spot podcast over on
spotify that that rail against joe rogan
being on spotify that's what you should
do
if you if you want to show spotify
how it works
now he's got a huge audience there's a
sh we have discovered this with trumpism
there is a [ __ ] shitload of [ __ ] bags
in this country a shitload of them
of these ninja poop nazis that are out
there these fascists they're out there
these fragile white [ __ ] males that
can't handle equality and equity they
think something's being taken from them
always whining and bitching and moaning
and complaining well i can't say what i
want to say and i'm being canceled you
have the biggest [ __ ] platform in
podcast you dumb [ __ ] you
talking to the microphone every goddamn
day
every [ __ ] day you're talking in the
microphone you're saying stupid [ __ ]
what are you talking about you don't
have the ability to [ __ ] to have
avoid your voice heard
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
stupid [ __ ] just because people
criticize you because your aim sucks
oh they're going to cancel all the white
males they're going to cancel all the
white white males nothing sounds more
[ __ ] weak to me than people bitching
about how they're going to cancel the
people who are in power
the [ __ ] out of here white men have
controlled this country and destroyed it
[ __ ] destroyed it a bunch of white
ball sacks
wreaking havoc on this country it's
enough of this [ __ ] and people aren't
buying it anymore and just because
people aren't buying the [ __ ]
anymore doesn't mean you have to whine
and [ __ ] and complain that they're not
buying it because 97 of the time you're
still in charge you dumb [ __ ]
a guy yelling and screaming into a
microphone with one of the biggest
audiences in the country complaining
that people are trying to silence him
so if you want to show spotify if you
want to do something to show spotify
what you think
what you should do is you should go over
spotify and you should download the [ __ ]
at a podcast
and music
of the like and content the like
that rebut joe rogan
that are the opposite of what joe
rogan's doing that's what you should do
that's what you should do
because they're making a [ __ ] [ __ ]
ton of money off joe rogan they are and
they're gonna continue to do that
why do you think they signed the
contract with joe rogan in the first
place do you think they signed a
contract with joe rogan in first aid
because he has all these prolific things
to say
no
jesus christ if if if spotify came to me
and said we really want to sign a
contract because you know you're you're
articulate and you definitely don't use
the word [ __ ]
what
no
they didn't sign him up for that
contract because he had all kinds of
prolific [ __ ] to say it's because his
audience is huge because there's this
huge need in this country to coddle
fragile white men and fragile white men
to hear the [ __ ] that they want to hear
even though it's [ __ ] lies
because they want to feel that like oh
we're losing something equality and
equity we're oppressed we want to be
oppressed so bad
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
so
again my view of the spotify thing is my
opinion
is [ __ ] spotify you don't have to
boycott spotify you know what you do you
go there and you download the [ __ ] out
of stuff that ain't joe rogan that's
what you do okay uh let's continue down
the sample music
is there any other is there any news
about this
that's um that's what i want to know is
there any news about it
now let's see what hal sparks have to
say
spotify has removed new young from the
service g
what is he going to do without the eight
dollars he gets from every
13 million plays spotify is a great way
to listen to your favorite artists while
making them broke buy their albums or
use apple music
[ __ ] spotify
[Laughter]
hal's making a point here
that
neil young neil young
i need to get hal on the show do you
guys want hal on the show
go go [ __ ] give him [ __ ] about
getting on the show i'd love to have hal
sparks on the show i watch i watch hal's
stream um
every once in a while like on youtube he
puts his vods up he streams on twitch
he's on he's on stuttering john's
podcast every once in a while too i've
watched him on there and i like hell and
he's been on minus touch a couple times
their podcast as well i like how we
should have on the show maybe maybe i'll
send him a message after the show i i've
never thought about it till now but hal
should be on the show
so hal if you're listening if you're
lushing out there contact contact my
agent i don't have an agent now i really
don't it's just me just [ __ ] me i
mean there's gabe here but he's not my
agent either
he just he just does the clips and and
does the funny videos does the funny
commercials okay let's see
he does keep it all together though gabe
like all the editing and [ __ ] and we
wouldn't have the interviews the way
they are without without without having
him
so if you like the interviews
[Laughter]
that's that's what it is i'd be [ __ ]
without without that okay let's see hey
i'm not
the apple music man the spotify thing
i don't want to talk about spotify
anymore clarence thomas it's in the
trendy trend still
damn phones ringing okay i thought i had
it on do not disturb
sorry about that okay
clarence thomas and his wife
um
you guys seen last week that clarence
thomas was the only one who dissented in
the uh the the opinion to make sure that
the january 6 select committee had all
the evidence they needed from the cheeto
dust kangaroo coup that came out of the
white house and the documents that
donald trump had um the only one was
clarence thomas now the other thing
about clarence thomas is his wife
jenny i guess her name is um
well here you go
uh this is from the other day but
brooklyn that finds as new according to
the new yorker clarence thomas's wife
jenny works with groups that directly
involved in the scotus cases
shouldn't he have recused so this is
about the affirmative action case
so not only is she tied up she tied up
in several cases here
she's tied up in the decision about the
executive order on the documents of
january 6 because she [ __ ] was
giving [ __ ]
funds to bus people to january 6. she
was funding it uh mayo says who else
demands that clarence thomas needs to
resign yeah maybe nikki haley will i
don't know hey mayo go go see what nikki
haley thinks about the conflict of
interest that's going on with clarence
thomas because not only is it the
january 6th select committee uh seeking
the records of donald trump and the
executive order um he uh
he
he was a conflict of interest there with
his wife ginny he also
he also
he also is a conflict of interest in
this case of affirmative action because
his wife is representing some of these
groups that have brought this case
it's like he's seeing his wife's case
almost in the court
it's [ __ ] ridiculous
um so maybe maybe just maybe um nikki
haley can run on over and see if she can
get um
see if she can get claire's thomas to
resign
let's see we got that we're 55 minutes
into now thanks for joining us today
here on the tony michaels podcast and
the shitless roundup
we really do appreciate it we'll be back
tomorrow noon eastern 11 central as we
are every weekday now
this is the first week we've almost made
it through the whole week and today is
episode 63.
we've done 63 episodes it's really gonna
start to pile up now you know we were
doing one a week sometimes two a week
when we were doing the guest interviews
you know it's months ago when we were
doing it that way yeah i used to have
the special guest episodes that would
air on friday man that seems like a
lifetime ago
now we're up to two hours every single
day
the good news about having the podcast
on every single day every single weekday
two hours a day
is is that it also appears on the the
podcast directory so spotify which
everyone's hating on today everyone
hates spotify today
by the way that's a thing i'm not i'm
not gonna hate on spotify we can hate on
joe rogan but um you know they're not
they're not gonna cancel the contract
it's too much money it's called
capitalism that's what that's what
they're gonna do
um and we just we just have to work
around it and the way you work around it
is you go download the content that
isn't joe rogan
and and
download the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of it
download the [ __ ] out of it i don't know
if you can but go download my podcast
500 times so we got 63 episodes after
today go download all of them on spotify
leave me five stars comment chris
you can comment womp womp over there too
go over there womp womp and you like to
comment that
now
our hey our local hate watcher here
chris
so
go download go download all my episodes
give me five stars on spotify you want
to beat back joe rogan on spotify you
want to show spotify go do that
show them
all the content that you like over there
go start downloading on spotify
that way you can you can you can
you can get it that way you can get at
them that way that's the best way to do
it you're not gonna you're not gonna win
by boycotting spotify his audience isn't
gonna stop listening to him that's the
shittiest part
is his audience is not gonna stop
listening to him these people are
[ __ ] boneheads they're going to
listen to bone-headed [ __ ]
that's how it's going to work
that is how it's going to work
also don't forget we're going to have
bonehead of the week tomorrow
second hour go you got one last chance
today go vote for the bonehead of the
week if you haven't already at tony
michael's pod follow us there at
tonymichaelspod also follow me at the
tony michaels and follow gabe at i am
gabe sanchez
follow all those accounts and you'll
you'll see uh gabe posted today the the
dishonorable mention
uh but we we showed it earlier let me
see let me pull it up here
it's somewhere on my feed of course you
know after i'm on the [ __ ] list round up
boy my feed gets full it gets full full
full full full there it is
here it is boom there it is
there's there's the uh there it is bump
matt gatz is our dishonorable mention
this week on the bonehead of the week so
don't miss that tomorrow in the second
hour of the podcast noon eastern 11
central join us tomorrow make sure
you're here
make sure you're here and if you're not
on time that's okay if you're not on
time you can subscribe to the youtube
channel we we it replays there you can
always replay anything that you missed
and then i'll clip it up and there's
certain things that we need to clip up
and put on the youtube channel and so
hit the bell alert and whatever the hell
it is to make sure you get notified if
there's clips that are available because
we'll also air bonehead of the week on
sundays eight eastern
in the in the evening that way you guys
can re-watch the bonehead of the week in
and of itself and also on monday don't
forget go follow missy modell it's missy
modell m-o-d-e-l-l
on twitter
uh instagram and the tiki talks because
we're gonna have her interview on monday
we'll have that ready for monday because
we're doing the the mohan of the week
tomorrow
so until tomorrow at noon eastern 11
central surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking